هناك
توقف أرضي في مطارنا
وهذا الشيء موجود في السماء ، هذا
الشيء الذي تعتقد الولايات المتحدة الآن
أنه بالون تجسس للحكومة الصينية
يطير على ارتفاع 60 ألف قدم في الغلاف
الجوي فوق البلد ، ونحن نعلم
أن البالون قد انتهك
المجال الجوي الأمريكي والقانون الدولي ، وهو أمر
غير مقبول ، ظل مسؤولو الدفاع الأمريكيون
يتتبعونه عن كثب لعدة
أيام لمناقشة ما إذا كان سيتم إسقاطه
وإبلاغ الرئيس جو بايدن بأنه
سيكون أمرًا خطيرًا للغاية ، ونعتقد أنه
لا يمثل خطرًا على الأشخاص على
الأرض.  إنها تجتاز حاليًا
الولايات المتحدة القارية ، وبالتالي من منطلق
وفرة من الحذر ، وإدراكًا للتأثير
المحتمل على المدنيين على
الأرض من حقل حطام في الوقت الحالي ،
سنواصل الآن مراقبة
ومراجعة خيارات الأخبار العاجلة
قبل أيام فقط من وزير
كان من المقرر أن يسافر وزير الخارجية أنطوني بلينكين إلى بكين ، وهي
أعلى رحلة قامت بها الإدارة إلى
الصين حتى الآن ، وقد تم تأجيل الرحلة الآن
على الرغم من الاعتذار الصيني النادر
وادعى أن البالون كان
لأغراض مدنية وأنه طاف عن مسار
وجود منطاد المراقبة
في المجال الجوي للولايات المتحدة.  يعد انتهاكًا واضحًا
لسيادة الولايات المتحدة والقانون الدولي ، وهو
عمل غير مسؤول ، وأن
قرار جمهورية الصين الشعبية باتخاذ هذا الإجراء حتى من خلال
الزيارة المخطط لها
يضر
بالمناقشات الجوهرية التي كنا مستعدين
لجعل البنتاغون يقول إنه تم
اتخاذ خطوات من أجل  حماية الذكاء الحساس
الأهداف على الأرض ، يكون البالون
بحجم ثلاث حافلات مزودة
بألواح شمسية للطاقة
وقمر صناعي لمراقبة الحمولة ، وتشير البيانات الأخرى إلى أن
البالون ربما يكون قد نشأ
في وسط الصين مع أنماط الطقس التي
تدفعه للخارج فوق المحيط الهادئ
إلى كندا  وإلى الولايات المتحدة
حيث كانت تعبر
مونتانا وإلى ميسوري ، يمكنها
المناورة بنفسها وقد غيرت مسارها
الحالي الذي يطفو فوق المسؤولين الأمريكيين المركزيين كما يقول
المسؤولون الأمريكيون بينما يقدمون أكثر قليلاً
عن موقعه الدقيق ، فإن الجمهور
بالتأكيد لديه القدرة على البحث في
السماء وانظر إلى أين يوجد البالون
ولديهم عيون تدريب
وكاميرات غريبة نحو السماء ما هذا
الكوكب وقد
قال سكرتير جيك بلينكين إنه
سيعيد جدولة رحلته إلى بكين
بمجرد أن تسمح الظروف بهذه
الظروف لن يقولوا  ولكن من
الواضح أن درجة الحرارة يجب أن
تنخفض ، لقد سمعنا للتو الوزير بلينكين يقول
الآن إن الأولوية الأولى هي إخراج
هذا البالون من مجالنا الجوي ،
ويعتقد البنتاغون أن هذا قد يستغرق
عدة أيام أخرى في الواقع ، لذا
سيستمرون في مشاهدته وهو يطفو فوق  من خلال
إبقاء خياراتهم مفتوحة